more than 1 in 5 transgender women are
HIV positive in the u.s. of those 31%
report being denied care simply because
they're trans having providers talking
to them about religion talking to them
that they are going to hell keep on
misgendering their pronouns and using
their name assigned at birth and
preferred name the problem comes down to
a failure in policy this is how it works
the Center for Disease Control uses data
to determine who is most at risk that
data comes from health care providers
but there is no national mandate for
them to count transgender patients so as
far as the data goes they barely exist
the result trans women have historically
been categorized as gay and bisexual men
it matters because when it comes to
funding and it's not as if trans people
don't already face enough obstacles to
healthcare 43% are below the poverty
line
42% have been incarcerated and of that
42% more than half have gone over six
months without seeing a doctor
the part of our existence is taken away
per month we your thoughts daughter's we
are brethren we assisted the White House
has begun to address these issues a 2015
update of the National hiv/aids strategy
prioritized data collection for trans
people a mandate will go into effect in
in the meantime many trans women living
with HIV remain invisible in the
healthcare system
you